[Applaudissements]
on va s'arrêter là pour faire
fonctionner les appareils de notre
quotidien chauffage éclairage et
électroménager nous utilisons en moyenne
6180 kilowattheures d'électricité par
jour et encore c'est sans compter
l'électricité utilisée indirectement par
les réseaux publics le tramway
l'éclairage des rues la signalisation
pour celles dont on a besoin pour faire
tourner les usines pour vous donner une
idée avec ma petite installation cela
reviendrait à pédaler à très bonne
allure en permanence heureusement nous
avons d'autres solutions pour répondre à
nos besoins en énergie pour autant cette
électricité ne tombe pas du ciel
exactement elle provient d'une multitude
de centrales et d'installations qui
prennent des formes différentes et
surtout qui transforme en électricité
des sources d'énergie différentes
aujourd'hui il faut jongler entre toutes
ces différentes options de production
pour répondre au mieux à notre besoins
croissants en énergie merci gaspard je
vois que tu es au courant les facile
celle là c'est ce qu'on appelle le mix
énergétique et c'est ce dont nous allons
vous parler aujourd'hui
andulo
[Musique]
le mix énergétique
c'est le nom que l'on donne à la
combinaison des différents types
d'énergies dans notre production et
notre consommation d'énergie aujourd'hui
nous allons essentiellement nous
concentrer sur l'électricité et vous
allez voir ya de quoi faire pour démêler
tout cela je suis accompagné de gaspard
il va nous emmener découvrir la réalité
de ce mix énergétique sur le terrain
mais c'est surtout quelqu'un de très
pointu sur les grands enjeux de notre
planète et en particulier tout ce qui
concerne l'énergie on peut dire ça à
gaspard alors justement si la question
du mix énergétique nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il ya urgence
à améliorer la part que représentent ces
fameuses énergies renouvelables dans
cette production globale je vais donc
vous emmener voir du solaire de l'éolien
et même des centres particulièrement
stratégique dans la gestion de notre
consommation électrique commençons par
les fondamentaux il faut savoir qu'on ne
produit pas d'énergie à proprement
parler on l'apprend quelque part sous
une forme et on la transforme de manière
à la rendre facilement transportable et
utilisable en énergie électrique des
pigments
prenons un exemple concret une centrale
à charbon le charbon extrait du sol
contient une énergie chimique il libère
sous forme de chaleur lorsqu'il ball
cette chaleur va ensuite chauffer de
l'eau qui se transforme en vapeur qui
fait tourner un générateur lequel
produit de l'électricité
malheureusement ce processus génère des
produits secondaires le charbon aimé lui
co2 du dioxyde de carbone quand ils
volent ainsi que des particules fines
nocives pour notre santé autre souci
ce charbon n'est pas présent partout et
puis il faut aussi l'extraire ce qui
n'est pas sans conséquence ils
s'épuisent c'est la cas qu'on vienne les
énergies dites renouvelables
je m'explique ces énergies sont issues
de sources inépuisables le rayonnement
solaire le mouvement de l'air ou de
l'eau elles sont également issue de
sources renouvelables ou renouvelés
comme les déchets avec la méthanisation
pas besoin d'extraire un combustible ici
ou là avec toutes les implications que
cela peut avoir qu elles soient
écologiques ou politique alors bien sûr
il faut des matériaux pour construire
les installations
mais une fois en place elles sont tout à
fait propre pour résumer donner plus de
place aux énergies renouvelables permet
de ralentir des changements climatiques
développer les territoires et aussi
gagner en indépendance énergétique que
du bon toutefois pour en tirer
pleinement partie et favoriser leur
utilisation elle demande une gestion
fine et intelligente ici nous sommes
dans un centre de conduite de ces
énergies renouvelables à châlons en
champagne une équipe de 15 personnes
supervise 1000 éoliennes et 130
centrales solaires qui produisent
annuellement l'équivalent de la
consommation électrique de 3 millions de
personnes 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 sur ses écrans on voit en direct
la production en électricité de toutes
ses installations et on peut les
surveiller à distance et vérifier leur
bon fonctionnement pourquoi un tel
dispositif
il faut bien comprendre qu à grande
échelle l'électricité ne se stocke pas
une fois produite elle est envoyée sur
le réseau depuis les différents sites
pour être convoyé est directement
utiliser cet équilibre se fait à
l'échelle nationale il faut ajuster en
permanence la production d'électricité
des différentes installations avec la
demande tenez ici on voit en temps réel
la part des différentes énergies
produites à l'échelle nationale le 24
mars 2022 à midi pétante jaune celle
nucléaire 60% en bleu 7% ce sont les
barrages hydrauliques et son propre et à
si facile à adapter en fonction de la
demande en turquoise 3% l'éolien est là
orange celle solaire 16% logique les
midis effectivement la particularité de
l'énergie solaire et dans une moindre
mesure celle de l'énergie éolienne c'est
qu'elles sont variables en fonction des
conditions climatiques
alors pour compléter cette gestion fine
une des meilleures stratégies visa
multiplier les sources et les
installations en fonction des
spécificités de chaque territoire des
singes amis ça s'appelle le foisonnement
ça permet de lisser la production comme
on dit dans le jargon un pro et ça tombe
bien parce qu'on ne peut pas dire que
nous ayons trop d'installation à l'heure
actuelle les énergies renouvelables
représentent 19% de la production
électrique en france est clairement
c'est en dessous des recommandations de
l'ensemble de la communauté scientifique
est en dessous des objectifs que la
france s'est elle même fixées
aujourd'hui c'est encore l'hydraulique
qui représentent la part la plus
importante mais clairement la plus forte
progression
ce n'est au lien jamie
jolyane eh bien je crois que tu as
trouvé ta prochaine destination bon le
temps que gaspard se déplace pour aller
prendre l'air au sens propre du terme
profitons-en pour faire un point sur
l'éolien justement dans les grandes
lignes c'est assez simple généralement
produire un courant électrique consiste
à faire tourner un aimant au sein d'une
bobine de fil conducteur ou l'inversé
c'est ainsi que fonctionnent tous les
générateurs d'ailleurs ça ressemble déjà
un peu à une éolienne à quelques détails
près poulard d'une éolienne est donc de
capter au mieux l'énergie du vent une
énergie cinétique du à la masse et à la
vitesse de l'air des places et de la
transformer en une énergie mécanique
le mouvement de ses pales qui vont
ensuite faire tourner le générateur et
induire une énergie électrique pour y
parvenir
les éoliennes sont munis de trois pales
en général elles sont profilées comme
les ailes d'un avion pour tourner au
mieux sous l'effet du vent l'ensemble
permet de mettre en rotation un axe qui
alimente ensuite le générateur le tout
est perché en haut d'un mât pour être
bien exposés au vent car l'énergie
déployée par une masse d'air dépend en
grande partie que sa vitesse de
déplacement or en général le vent est
plus fort en altitude
au ras des pâquerettes
alors effectivement l'exposition au vent
c'est le nerf de la guerre typiquement
en dessous de 10 km heure le vent est
trop faible pour permettre aux éoliennes
de tournai où il arrive aussi que le
vent souffle trop fort mais c'est quand
même beaucoup plus rare lorsqu'on
installe un parc éolien on cherche donc
un endroit où le vent souffle
suffisamment fort et suffisamment
régulièrement comme c'est le cas ici
edit donc jamie c'est vachement bon j'ai
peut-être décembre ce sera plus pratique
pour vous parler ici nous sommes au
milieu du parc de la forêt de tivoli
cette zone a été choisi parce qu'il ya
de la place parce que les éoliennes
peuvent s'intégrer dans le paysage mais
surtout parce que le vent souffle
concrètement on recherche plutôt une
courbe comme celle-là des éoliennes qui
tournent en moyenne entre 75 et 95 % du
temps si elle ne tourne pas c'est que le
vent est trop faible trop fort c'est
plus rare ou qu'elles sont en
maintenance un parc comme celui ci
représente la consommation électrique de
près de 14000 personnes alors à
l'échelle nationale on essaye de
multiplier les zones d'implantation des
parcs éoliens de la même manière qu'on
multiplie les sources d'énergie
renouvelables
le mieux étant de choisir des zones
soumises à des régimes vente différents
pour qu'à tout moment puisse compter sur
une partie de ce parc global éparpillés
un peu partout sur le territoire et pour
continuer dans un style toujours plus il
faut de la place
exactement mais il y à un endroit où il
y a de la place et pas mal de vent c'est
en mer on appelle cela l'éolien offshore
au delà des côtes ces parcs se développe
un peu partout dans le monde car la
technologie commence à devenir très
compétitive leur impact sur la
biodiversité marine est étudiée de près
pour être constamment diminué ces
éoliennes ont l'avantagé de produire ou
plutôt de transformer de grandes
quantités d'énergie éolienne en énergie
électrique
alors que la puissance maximale d'une
éolienne terrestre est généralement
comprise entre 1,8 et 3 mégawatts les
éoliennes offshore atteignent facilement
6 8 mégawatts et ce sans compter les
projets d'éoliennes offshore actuelle
qui vise une bonne quinzaine de
mégawatts certains parcs et valises
d'ailleurs déjà avec des centrales
nucléaires notamment dans les mers
septentrionales la mer du nord la mer
baltique le vent au large des côtes est
plus puissant et plus régulier que sur
terre d'ailleurs en france aussi de
nombreux projets sont en train de sortir
de terre enfin de mer
ces projets de grande envergure sont
indispensables pour réussir un
changement global dans nos méthodes de
production de l'électricité et on sait
ce changement est urgent mais ce n'est
pas la seule voix il existe des
solutions qui fonctionnent très bien
pour les projets de grandes comme de
petite envergure et qui sont
parfaitement adaptés à notre
environnement c'est le cas des panneaux
photovoltaïques ils tirent parti d'une
énergie tout aussi est limité et
abondante que le vent celle que nous
procure le soleil gaspard il est temps
de mettre les voiles et d'aller prendre
le soleil s'il est là avec plaisir ça
commence à payer par ici il y a deux
fondamentaux indispensables à la
compréhension du fonctionnement de ces
panneaux d'une part ils sont en silicium
et comme toute la matière qui nous
entoure ce silicium est composée
d'atomes et grain de matière constitué
d'un noyau autour duquel se balade des
électeurs d'autre part il faut savoir
qu'un courant électrique c'est justement
une circulation d'électrons le but est
donc d'obtenir une circulation
d'électrons autres les atomes de
silicium et plus généralement entre les
deux couches de silicium qui composent
un panneau pour y parvenir il faut créer
d'un côté surplus d'électrons et de
l'autre un déficit d'électrons sur la
couche supérieure on va donc ajouter des
atomes de phosphore des atomes qui
possède un surplus d'électrons et son
nom porteur d'une charge négative sur la
couche inférieure
on y place des atomes de bord eux
présentent un déficit d'électrons une
charge positive quand le dispositif se
retrouve exposé à la lumière du soleil
les électrons sont excités par cet
apport d'énergie ils sont prêts à
circuler qui compte vers le bas ou plus
précisément du moins vers le plus il
suffit de connecter les deux couches
avec un fil conducteur
est un courant secret alimentant au
passage
les appareils qui sont reliés au système
comme je le disais l'avantagent des
panneaux photovoltaïques c'est qu'ils
peuvent facilement être installés un peu
partout sur le toits de nos maisons des
bâtiments agricoles les bâtiments
publics industriels les grandes surfaces
et de la place effectivement selon une
étude qu'il a de 2019 en europe on
pourrait couvrir un quart de nos besoins
en électricité en recouvrant de toit de
panneaux solaires quand c'est possible
bien sûr ce genre d'initiative peut
également s'accompagner de projets plus
ambitieux typiquement il est possible
d'installer de véritables parcs
photovoltaïques comme pour l'éolien
regarde derrière moi
[Musique]
bon et tant qu'à faire pour ce genre
d'installation on essaie de choisir des
zones où l'ensoleillement est optimale
comme ici à lui c'est dans le sud ouest
on n'est pas sur un 100 % de justesse la
niveau météo sur ce site de 25 hectares
près de quarante mille panneaux sont
installés pour une puissance de 12
mégawatts alors c'est moins qu'un parc
éolien offshore mais ça représente tout
de même la consommation de 7400
personnes et une fois que ces panneaux
sont construits et installés ils
fournissent une électricité propre alors
il faut veiller à entretenir le parc
régulièrement et s'assurer de son bon
fonctionnement
autre avantage on peut concilier sur le
même espace deux activités ici avec un
élevage de moutons par exemple eh bien
henri chercher ne les comptait pas un
c'est pas le moment de s'endormir car il
faut bien garder à l'esprit que ces
installations ne sont pas éternels un
panneau solaire a une durée de vie
moyenne de 30 ans au bout d'un moment il
faudra en changer et le remplacer par un
autre cela pose la question de cycle de
vie pour les produire tout d'abord il
faut de l'énergie et des matières
premières du silicium en grande quantité
dont l'extraction et le raffinage ont
des impacts environnementaux et sociaux
particulièrement en chine cependant des
producteurs européens et même français
parviennent à limiter considérablement
les impacts on est sur la bonne voie
question fin de vie ces panneaux sont
recyclables à 95 voire 99 % et plus il y
en a plus la filière se développe côté
éolien maintenant là aussi les choses
avancent plus de 90 % du poids d'une
éolienne est recyclable
après le démantèlement il reste les
pâles mais il existe des filières pour
les valorisés énergétiquement et
certaines pâle 100% recyclable et éco
conçus commencent à voir le jour n'est
pas encore parfait donc mais il faut
garder en tête que malgré cela ces
installations émet pts au final des
bises deux fois moins de co2 par
kilowattheure produit que les énergies
fossiles une raison de plus pour
explorer toutes les pistes et développer
les différentes filières dans cette
vidéo nous avons beau nous est concentré
sur l'éolien et le solaire deux secteurs
très emblématique il ne faut pas non
plus oublier le reste l'hydroélectricité
évidemment qui est l'une des plus
anciennes les nerfs du monde il y aussi
le biogaz produit à partir de déchets
agricoles notamment la géothermie très
prisée en islande mais qui est aussi
utilisé en france qui repose sur la
gestion de la chaleur du sous-sol on
peut aussi penser à la force marémotrice
qui s'appuie sur les va et vient de la
marée ou les hydroliennes qui récupère
l'énergie des courants marins bref des
sources d'énergie intarissable et
adaptée aux spécificités de chaque
territoire et l'idée en fait c'est de ne
pas mettre tous nos oeufs dans le même
panier de parier sur une multitude de
solutions c'est ça le mix énergétique en
plus la question du stockage de
l'énergie est aussi une des clés pour
encourager le développement des énergies
variable aux produits au maximum en
permanence et on stocke le surplus pour
le réutiliser plus tard il y une
dernière chose qu'il ne faut jamais
perdre de vue la seule énergie propre
est celle qu'on ne consomme pas la
sobriété
ça ne peut donc pas faire de mal à
grande échelle évidemment mais aussi à
titre individuel quand c'est possible
et d'ailleurs j'ai mis tu prends mon
vélo parce que là j'ai deux heures de
marche 1 jusque chez moi euh oui il faut
simplement que je remette la main sur la
roue enfin la bonne nouvelle c'est que
comme ça et a plus besoin d'anti vol
[Applaudissements]